hi this is preshtalwalker can you figure
out why there's a missing square
on a piece of graph paper i will draw
two triangles
i'll fill the remaining area with
rectangular shapes
i'm now going to rearrange these four
figures
to reconstruct the triangle in a
different way
i'll move the two triangles
and then i'm going to move the two
rectangular figures to fill the
remaining area
we have now essentially reconstructed
the same triangle with the same
dimensions but we have a clear problem
there's a missing square in this new
triangle
since both triangles are constructed of
the four same shapes the question is
where did this missing square come from
how is this possible
this puzzle is a classic geometric
problem
it's known as a dissection puzzle and i
challenge you to figure out why there's
a missing square in the second figure
if you can't figure it out or you want
to check your solution i posted a link
in the video description to a blog post
where i give a complete explanation of
why there's a missing square and i also
give the theoretical reason
for the dimensions
and how this construction works
it's pretty cool so you should
definitely check it out
thanks for watching this video
i hope you enjoyed it
and please subscribe to my channel i
make videos on math and game theory
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon
you can also catch me at preshtalwalker
on twitter instagram tumblr and
pinterest
and if you like this video please check
out my books about math
there are some really cool topics that
i've covered including mental math
tricks
this video itself comes from my book 40
paradoxes in logic probability and game
theory
check it out there's a link in the video
description